this is I think absolutely the biggest
issue going on right now and very few
people are talking about it
unfortunately net neutrality which
basically means that the Internet
service providers have to give equal
access to everything online it has been
struck down by a court this this is
really quite terrible so let's look at
the definition of just a basic
definition of what net neutrality is so
it's the principle that all sites on the
internet will be equally accessible so
if you have time warner let's say for
internet they can't slow down sites that
they are not affiliated with so the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals ruled in
verizon's favor the court said that
because the FCC had previously placed
broadband internet service in a separate
regulatory category from phone service
it lacked legal justification to impose
the open Internet rules okay so that's a
lot of mumbo jumbo but basically verizon
wants to be able to control if you have
verizon as your internet provider they
want to give you access to their stuff
and their partners faster than other
stuff I think this is huge this is so
horrible and that neutrality is so
important this is I really think this
this and the NSA are like the two
defining things of our generation why
isn't this a bigger deal no it should be
especially because like you just know
that when this sort of power is put into
the hands of conglomerates like Time
Warner Cable who I'm a subscriber to
only because they're like a monopoly in
my neighborhood like they're totally
gonna exploit it you know to the best of
their ability and I just think it's
awful it's terrible it's it's is awful
but it's it's all so shocking to me that
the people who are making these
decisions these judges these like do
they understand what's going like it's
the same I have the same issue with that
I have whenever Congress gets involved
in anything on the Internet it's like
these people are like laughs at the guy
who comes in to give them because he's a
nerd because of to give them like
information I I don't trust them to
actually know the implications of what
this means they I don't think these are
people who are using the internet the
same way that young people are 19 young
people like adults now like the next
generation of people are using the
Internet
and it is I mean the one silver lining
yeah is that it's been set at comcast
for instance is going to continue hat is
committed to continuing that neutrality
through 2018 which does give us time to
potentially legislate or you know find
other routes to net neutrality it's just
the court decisions like this make that
a lot yeah so isn't this one of those
stories that it goes to what we started
with here the Bieber thing and the eggs
like that's the story that leads cnn.com
the same day the net neutrality gets
struck down because we it's too hard to
explain i think I did a pretty decent
two-sentence job of it but like you'd
have to actually understand some
technical things as opposed to eggs on a
window my god what the implications are
that like a company like like Time
Warner could charge extra for you know
HD youtube streams or something like
that or like give slower access to
shopping sites if they decided to launch
their own right right which is terrible
no it's it's all terrible yeah it's
awful and the fact that we don't have a
market place right now where you have
options you kind of alluded to that but
like it's not like I can leave Time
Warner tomorrow and go to cablevision
cuz they're good they're not out here
bell time water timelines and tortilla
that we're start with him I got I think
maybe I have an AT&T choice which I've
heard is really bad for Internet yeah
because there's no alternative and they
are and they already like you know are
terrible you know in terms of customer
service and and like I use them and I've
had nothing but awful experiences with
them yeah and this will just turn the
internet into cable TV which is the
problem is that you can get a basic
subscription that will give you email
and basic browsing but then if you want
netflix you have to pay this much you
want and nobody wants that there's
nobody but the conglomerates that want
that and this is another example just it
nothing that isn't the public's interest
but yeah there's no regular human being
who's like I actually prefer my internet
Yeah right if that's the case if there's
no human being who's like this is a
better option why would we do that
actually really doesn't it doesn't go to
everything we talked about with politics
all the time here is that they're making
all these decisions and the last people
that are involved they're actually the
people nobody wants this i have i have
yet to hear anyone outside of this judge
basically and and comcast and time
warner the people that are gonna profit
for
it says okay do you guys think we're
gonna look back on the 20 years let's
say that we've all that the internet is
really existed since let's say the late
nineties when uh was Netscape started
the whole thing or whatever was a
prodigy do you think we look back on it
as like the golden age of the internet
like we look back on the Golden Age of
TV because now between this and the NSA
so now it's like we got people watching
us and they're controlling how fast we
can get stuff that that uh that the
first 20 years we know they were
watching and before they could control
the access you think we look back and
and think wow it was it was pretty good
the Wild West I do I also maybe I'm
naive i still hope that's not gonna
happen like I think and maybe that's the
wrong message to send maybe the message
centers like this guy's calling this guy
is following like lets you know people
of America do something like but I i
think that at the end of the day I just
I look at what happened with like SOPA
and nobody cared and then the last
minute everybody realized how bad it was
and Congress like got in line and did
the right thing yeah temporarily right
and i'm sure that's probably gonna be
flipped to it so as well yeah but I just
I do think that it there's still time
like I don't think it's over yet like
and maybe that's knife maybe I'm the guy
its bottom of 9th amor down 30 runs and
I'm like I got it we can still do it
guys but you know right what do you
think we'll look at it back as the
Golden Age don't you see it the winds
have changed as well I'm always I tend
to be optimistic I think like as is the
case with most technologies once the
genie is out of the bottle you know you
can't easily put it back in and so I
think that like if people are really
dissatisfied as I am assuming they will
be you know I think I don't think that
they'll let it happen yeah yeah i think
the other kind of x factor in all this
is yes there are corporations like
comcast and time warner and verizon who
want to end at net neutrality but google
doesn't write facebook doesn't and those
are also giant companies with huge I
mean Google specifically is also rolling
out broadband in a lot of places yeah
and like it within I mean that's going
to change here in Los Angeles like
Google broadband is going to be a thing
in a few years and that's it could be
there like maybe the answer to this is
google ends up being
like all right [ __ ] you guys will be the
internet right so there's your solution
people we need an even bigger giant
corporations who say by Google Fiber I
think it's just in Kansas and maybe
Texas right now has to come to save it